[Music]
in the 3rd century bc
greek scientist eratosthenes was the
first to calculate the circumference of
our planet by measuring the length of
shadows in two different cities
at the same time of day proving that the
world we live in is
indeed spherical rather than a flat
plain however
it wouldn't be until 1967 that the first
colored picture of the earth in its
entirety was made by the american ats-3
satellite
which makes me think what about the
fantasy world of zelda
although it has very little impact on
the story beats of the series
as someone with a keen interest in
astronomy i've always secretly wondered
what this world in its entirety would
look like
every game in the series takes place in
its own confined area of land and maps
provided by the game will show how said
land is laid out
but we've never been given an accurate
depiction of the world as a whole
the closest we get is fan art made by
zelda enthusiasts who attempted to
sketch an overall idea
but nothing official from nintendo
themselves has ever been published
so is hyrule a planet well
yes and no if you were to ask if hyrule
is located on the planet then
yes but if the question is is the planet
named hyrule
then no hyrule is just a stretch of land
among many
a kingdom which has expanded contracted
and relocated
many times throughout zelda's history
it's understandable that some might
confuse hyrule as the name of the planet
since some of the wording in the
creation story seems to hint at this
stating things such as the goddesses
descended onto the chaos that was
hyrule but there is a simple explanation
for this the creation myth as presented
is always told from the vantage point of
beings who live
in and around hyrule it's not uncommon
for tales of creation to be centered
around the culture
and land from which it originated in the
japanese shinto creation story
japan is the first landmass to be
created similarly the ancient greeks and
romans too had stories revolving around
gods creating and settling
unrecognizable landmarks within their
own territory such as crete and mount
olympus
in turn placing themselves and their
land at the heart of the creation story
as such it's easy to believe that the
hylians and other inhabitants of the
kingdom pass on the stories of creation
in a way that it places them
at the center of it all after all in
their eyes hyrule is the superior
kingdom chosen by the gods in reality
the gods created so much more than just
the land of hyrule
but how do we know for sure that hyrule
is located on a planet and not some flat
plain floating around in a void
or some sort of magic snow globe well
first off we have the presence of the
sun and moon
two celestial bodies we are all too
familiar with if the moon is a sphere it
only makes sense that the world itself
is two as per the laws of gravity unless
you want to join the flat earth society
who don't believe in a round earth but
do acknowledge that mars is a sphere
alrighty then
we also see stars in the sky and other
traits one would find on a planet like
our own such as sunrise and sunset
seasons plate tectonics and even
specific weather events such as storms
are only possible on a spherical world
but these are all scientific
explanations something the developers
could have easily just
copied from our own world since these
are things that are familiar to us
after all without gravity the games
would be
very different in general it's no use
comparing the gravity from the zelda
series to
those of our own world one because the
strength of gravity isn't universal and
slightly varies between titles depending
on the engine
and two because most games generally
simulate something close to earth's
gravity
even those that don't take place on
earth
however there is actual in-game evidence
feign's witch directly hint at the
existence of a planet
on which the series takes place for
instance the presence of globes
inside tetra's cabin aboard her pirate
ship we find what seems to be a full
representation of the planet
we also find a stranger variant of a
globe inside the astral observatory in
majora's mask
as well as a research note plastered on
the wall which seems to depict a green
planet
with the moon orbiting around it so yes
the events of the zelda series most
likely take place on a planet
but then what is its name well as boring
as it might sound
earth throughout the series the word
earth is used on many different
occasions to describe the world as a
whole
we also have an interview with siri's
former and current producers
shigeru miyamoto and aeginuma in which
they state this fact
so the land's hyrule what's the planet
called
although this interview is definitely
humoristic and playful in nature
do notice how miyamoto is very quick and
resolute in his reaction
he's been the producer of the series
since its inception
and set most of the standards for the
series back in the day
until the baton was passed to enuma
hence many of the series tropes
including the first bits of the overall
lore originated from him
this begs the question though if this is
earth is it
our earth well again yes and no in a way
this
is indeed the same planet we inhabit
however it's not set in our timeline or
even our reality if this confuses you i
think tolkien said it best when he was
asked
a similar question about his fantasy
world most people have made this mistake
anything in middle earth is a particular
kind of earth or is another planet and
you know in the science fiction song but
it's simply an old-fashioned word for
the
for this world we live in as imagined
surrounded by the ocean
it seemed to me that that middle earth
was was in a sense as you say
this world we live in but um this world
we live in at a different era
no at a different stage of imagination
but you make no attempt at all to tie
this up with time as we know it today
why is this because it had been
impossible
it won't really work out you know either
paleontologically or archaeologically at
all actually
i mean then you can't really relate the
landmasses i described them
satisfactorily to the landmasses we know
now
as tolkien states it is indeed our
planet it is earth
in a different state of imagination and
this too seems to apply to the fantasy
world of zelda
some games do establish that it takes
place in our reality
they loosely follow real-life events
such as wars or other significant parts
of our history
others take place far far into the
future when mankind is much more
advanced
yet other games like fallout have a bit
of both everything leading up to its
prologue is based on our timeline but
then it veers off into its own reality
one in which nuclear power was fully
embraced after the second world war
resulting in an alternate version of the
1950s where technology is way more
advanced than it was in real life
but in the zelda series there's nothing
that suggests that it's supposed to take
place in our own reality
it seems to follow its own timeline and
history and even in the technology
department it's
all over the place on the one hand we
see technology which reflects those from
medieval times
on the other hand we see things that far
outshine our current day advancements
the zelda series also doesn't seem to
bother much with keeping track of
actual dates everything is categorized
in eras like the era of the sky
or the era of light and dark and so on
and in a lot of cases these eras
are separated by huge amounts of time
often indicated by
ages or eons so there's no real way of
telling when a game takes place
all we can determine is the order
there's only one game which
actually mentions a specific date which
is the wind waker on windfall island we
can find a tombstone with hylian text on
it the translation of which tells us
that a great artist is buried here
accompanied by a year of birth and death
831-894 of course it's impossible to
deduce anything from this
the wind waker is set to take place only
about a hundred years after ocarina of
time but we have no idea when the
hylians started keeping count and it's
obvious that it doesn't encompass the
zelda timeline as a whole as skyward
sword and minish cap alone already take
place many ages apart
definitely a lot longer than 800 years
it's a bit similar to how our current
day calendar only started counting a
little over two millennia ago but it is
at least
interesting to see an actual date pop up
in the zelda timeline
but let's get back to the planet itself
which as we established is called earth
and is in fact based on our earth and we
have plenty of evidence for this
if this was just some far-off planet in
a galaxy far far away
it likely wouldn't have been called
earth first of all
the sun and moon would have had
different names as well the sun
or soul is simply the name of our home
star
and the moon or luna the name of the
companion orbiting us
so far people have been able to match at
least three familiar constellations in
various games which all match
exactly with those from our real world
orion
big dipper and cassiopeia if hyrule's
planet was an alien planet
either in a different part of the milky
way or even a different galaxy
altogether
the presence of these constellations
would be impossible
though the stars in the sky appear as a
two-dimensional plane or dome wrapped
around the earth
the actual distance between each
individual star is vastly different
the patterns we've laid out for them
only work from the vantage point
of our planet move to a different point
in space and the alignments would no
longer be the same
if zelda had its own made-up
constellations this wouldn't have been
an issue
but a celestial pattern such as a famous
big dipper would only be visible from
the vantage point
of our planet more interestingly
constellations seem to be
of more importance in the zelda universe
than just a decorative reference
to our own world stargazing and
celestial patterns
are recurring theme in the zelda series
in the wind waker a picture of orion can
be found inside tetris cabin right next
to the globe we mentioned earlier
we also find three islands with patterns
matching that of the three
constellations we
previously listed in majora's mask an
astral observatory stands in the central
fields of termina
its occupant professor shakashi doing
vigorous research into the night sky
notes of celestial bodies strange
otherworldly crystals
and other curiosities scattered around
the floor and walls of the observatory
in twilight princess we can clearly
observe the recognizable three-star belt
of orion in the night sky
and this obsession with celestial
alignments was taken to the extreme in
2017's breath of the wild
although there are no constellations
visible in the night sky this time
around they do play a prominent role in
the game's lore
particularly that of the ancient chica
and their mysterious technology
constellations are found all over their
machines in architecture
most notably the star map inside the
giant dome-shaped room inside hyrule
castle
which is confirmed to be an astral
observatory we also find
giant shika telescopes used to study the
night skies at the two main laboratories
above ground
as of right now it remains a mystery why
these constellations are so
important to the sheikah though there
are plenty of theories
it has never been confirmed why nintendo
has such a specific interest in orion
the big dipper and cassiopeia
it's definitely a reoccurring thing they
keep putting in on purpose but there are
some real-life
ancient legends and customs which might
explain their inclusion
the big dipper is the easiest to explain
as it has an interesting meaning in
various asian cultures
in shintoism the big dipper which
consists of seven stars represents the
seven divine generations of kami
however even more on the nose is its
meaning in indian astronomy
here the big dipper was initially called
the bear but was later more commonly
known by the name of sapterishi
or seven sages hence it could very well
be possible that the inclusion of the
big dipper is meant to symbolize the
famous seven sages of hylian legends
orion is a bit harder to pinpoint in
terms of its meaning or symbolism as it
has many different meanings especially
in japanese mythology but it is a
constellation that plays some degree of
importance in both shinto
and buddhist traditions and is closely
tied to either music
ancestral spirits or specific deities
but if the fact that tetra has this
constellation in particular framed on
her desk has any deeper meaning is
unclear at this point cassiopeia is very
interesting when put into context with
the game it's most prominently featured
in that being the wind waker
cassiopeia was a queen in ancient greek
mythology according to legend she
angered poseidon the god of the sea
who then sent a sea monster cetus to
ravage the kingdom
given the wind waker's theme of a
kingdom ravaged and swallowed up by the
sea
it couldn't be more fitting to have this
constellation make its appearance here
all the myths and symbolism aside it
could also be that nintendo included
these three constellations in particular
because they are generally well known
throughout all cultures
in breath of the wild we find another
common trait of that of a planet
that being these enormous craters likely
caused by meteorite impacts on the
surface of hyrule
meteors of course being rocks who
originate from the vacuum of space
as well as star fragments basically
small glassy meteorites raining down
from space and onto hyrule's landscape
since the evidence suggests that hyrule
is indeed a planet with a moon and
orbiting a star
aka the sun one would assume based on
our real life experience
that it is part of a larger solar system
in other words
are there other worlds out there as well
the short answer is likely
yes there are some small hints which
indicate the presence of other planets
one of these being two research notes
found on the floor of the astral
observatory in majora's mask
although very crude they seem to depict
a solar system with various celestial
bodies orbiting around a center point
this could be proof that indeed other
planets exist out there
second is the existence of well
aliens yes unlike our real world the
zelda universe has
undeniable proof of alien visitation
there have been quite some videos and
theories about the strange ghostly
entities visiting romani ranch
only known as them or they speculations
surrounding these otherworldly beings
have attempted to write them off as
simply
ghosts or some other earthly or magical
phenomena
but time and time again the evidence
heavily leans towards actual alien
visitors
from the creature they were based on
that being a real-life alien encounter
from west virginia
to quotes from the game's producer ag
onuma to photographs of
ufos not to mention the fact that it has
all the tropes of classic american
abduction stories involving either cows
and even people getting snatched up by
aliens
and there is one more interesting piece
of evidence that hints to these
creatures originating from the skies
above
those who are familiar with the side
quest know that the alien attack on the
ranch takes place on the first night of
majora's three-day cycle
if we look to the sky on the night of
the first day we can see a red star
right above the big dipper constellation
at first people speculated that this
might be beetlejuice
a giant star 700 times bigger than our
own sun
which is part of the orion constellation
this star can actually be seen glowing
red
even with the naked eye however as
mentioned before the red star in
majora's mask is located right above the
big dipper
not orion more interestingly however
on the second and third night the star
is
gone it disappears from the night sky
this coincides with the alien attack on
the first night
after which they take off and are never
seen again
if these are indeed aliens which the
evidence seems to suggest
this means that they had to have
originated from another planet out there
somewhere
of course aside from the singular
encounter the possible presence of other
planets has little to no bearings on the
overarching story events of the zelda
series as a whole
at least not right now however it does
open the door to future possibilities
we've seen from breath of the wild
concept art that nintendo has been
toying around the idea of aliens being
the main threat to hyrule and its heroes
and although this concept was ultimately
scrapped who is to say that this won't
become a reality in the future
perhaps they might even go as far as to
have us visit
one or more of these alien worlds who
knows
until then we can only imagine
one final thing to address is the
radical changes in hyrule's geography
between each installment
in my opinion there's two valid
explanations for this
well three actually the first is the
most likely and also
the most boring one since it's more
grounded in reality and that is that
nintendo simply
doesn't care about consistency and
values gameplay above
anything else after all exploring the
exact same hyrule every time would get
boring after so many games
the second one is that the landscape
changes from game to game due to all
kinds of natural factors like plate
tectonics
catastrophic events and generally just
nature being nature
i've attempted to piece this together in
my evolution of hyrule series with a
mild level of success but there were
many things which were very hard or even
impossible to explain or at least
required severely stretching it
ultimately i even had to give up on some
games because the changes were simply
too radical
but the evolution series was never
intended to find a solid explanation for
everything and was more or less a
thought experiment to see how far we
could get in coming up with reasons why
which is where the third explanation
comes in there is a much more elegant
and simple solution for this phenomena
without mentioning game design or
trying to explain every individual
change in hyrule's landmarks
and the solution is hidden in the title
of the series
the legend of zelda the idea is that
every game in the series is a distant
legend that you
the player experienced as if it was
being retold by someone
and as is with all legends and ancient
myths the accounts and details of what
happened and how the landscape looked
exactly
quickly blurs over time lost in
translation through the many retellings
of set's story
we don't actually need to explain why a
forest is here and then all of a sudden
here in the next game all that matters
is that there was a forest called
the lost wood somewhere and that some
significant events took place here
this approach essentially solves any
inconsistency the theory has when it
comes to its geography
there is even more to mention about the
world of zelda as everything i've
described here is within the scope of
the quote-unquote normal world
also referred to as the world of light
or light world but
as many of you know the zelda series is
rife with alternate dimensions or realms
many of which are almost impossible to
pinpoint where exactly these could be
located relative to hyrule there's also
a lot of conflicting information about
which lands are parallel dimensions and
which are not
and to this day we still have no clear
understanding of what termina
actually is if it's a completely
different reality on a different plane
of existence or if it's simply located
somewhere else on the planet but still
on the same physical plane as hyrule
as such different realms are best saved
for a future video as they are a whole
other topic altogether
i hope you enjoyed this deep dive into
the universe of the legend of zelda and
i hope to see you in the next video
first off a big thanks to nintendo black
crisis for once again being my partner
in crime for this one he'll be releasing
his own video next week so be sure to
check it out when it's ready
i'll put a link to it in the description
as soon as it's up and of course a
massive thanks as always goes to my
supporters right here on youtube
and on patreon you guys are the best oh
and please say hello to sakamoto
shinonome for joining my patreon crew
and to perry of hyrule who finally
decided to become a member thank you
perry
it is greatly appreciated and that is
all for now
this is don signing off and have a good
[Music]
[Music]
one
[Music]
you